Guten Tag, mein Name ist Bulur. Ich bin der Dienstherber, der Arztin auf der Station und würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, ja, Frau Dr.
So als werde ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann können wir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen. Dann, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Ella Krast.
Frau Krast, können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen beschreiben?
Ella mit E, doppel L, A, Krast mit K, R, A, T, Z.
A, S, Z.
K, R, A, T, Z.
T, Z, okay. Krast.
Krast, okay. Danke schön. Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Krast?
Ja, ich bin 39, Frau Dr.
39, okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1986.
5.8.1986
5.8.
Ja
Okay, 5.8.
Okay, danke schön. Und wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ich bin 1,71 Meter.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 61 Kilo.
61, okay. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Ja, Herr Föller.
Herr Föller mit doppel L, E, A?
Ja, doppel L, E, A.
Okay, und wie sind Sie versichert?
Ja, AOK. Mein Versichertes ist AOK.
Okay, danke schön für diese Informationen, Frau Krast.
Und was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Frau Dr., ehrlich zu sagen, habe ich sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
Das kann ich nicht ertragen. Das ist sehr schlimm.
Okay, haben Sie jetzt Kopfschmerzen auch?
Ja, habe ich jetzt auch.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Ja, besonders seit zwei Tagen habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Und manchmal kommt es und geht wieder.
Aber heute Morgen beginnt es und ich muss sofort eine Notaufnahme besuchen.
Okay, früher war es wellenformig, aber jetzt dauert es.
Ja, seit zwei Tagen habe ich eine Anfalldauer von 1-2 Stunden.
Seit zwei Tagen habe ich sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
Okay, könnten Sie beschreiben, wo genau Ihre Schmerzen sind?
Ja, das ist im linken Seite.
Im Gesicht fühle ich auch Schmerzen.
Und manchmal fühle ich den Hinterkopf sehr stark.
Okay, wie stark?
Im linken Seite kann ich sagen.
Okay, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, manchmal fühle ich in meinem Hinterkopf auch linke Augen.
Besonders vorne, links und vorne.
Aber auch in den Augen.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1.000 Sehen,
wobei eine sehr lafte Sehne sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, das kann ich jetzt sagen, 7 oder 8. Das ist schlimm.
Könnten Sie das Gespräch bis zum Ende erhalten oder brauchen Sie jetzt einen Schmerzmittel?
Ja, wie viele Minuten dauert das Gespräch, Frau Doktor?
Ja, es dauert ca. 20 Minuten oder 15 Minuten.
Ja, ich kann warten, Frau Doktor. Ich kann warten jetzt.
Okay, ich werde Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel geben, wenn wir das Gespräch fertig.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher Schmerzen gehabt oder...
Ja, ich hatte es drei Mal.
In den letzten drei Jahren hatte ich drei Mal Kopfschmerzen.
Aber diese Anfallung ist sehr schlimm.
Okay, haben Sie einen Arzt oder andere Arzt für diese Schmerzen besucht?
Ja, ich habe regelmäßig meinen Hausarzt besucht.
Aber seit zwei Tagen habe ich viele Schmerzmittel angenommen, aber es hat nicht geholfen.
Okay, welche Schmerzmittel haben Sie angenommen?
Ich habe die Prophangenomen, Aspirin, Paracetamol, Trieptan haben angenommen, aber es hat nicht gut geholfen.
Okay, ich verstehe. Das kann nicht sehr gut sein, aber ich werde Ihnen so schnell wie möglich helfen.
Okay, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöse für Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, Frau Doktor, meine Arbeit ist sehr stressig.
Ich habe mit meinen Kollegen in der Arbeit gestritten.
Okay, ich verstehe. Sie haben eine stressige Arbeit.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen mit Ihrem Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ich habe Übelkeit und heute Morgen habe ich dreimal Erbruch.
Dreimal Erbruch. Wie sah Ihr Erbruch aus?
Ja, das war Frühstückrest.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Oder Schütterfrust?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefühlt.
Okay. Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nein, nein habe ich nicht. Aber ich konnte gestern Abend nicht schlafen.
Vielleicht wegen Schmerzen.
Okay.
Ja, kein...
Okay, ich verstehe. Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ja, seit gestern mein Appetit ist auch nicht gut. Heute Morgen habe ich ein bisschen gefrühstückt, aber habe ich alle zurückgegeben.
Okay. Leiden Sie unter Müdigkeit oder Abgeschlagenheit?
Ja, ich fühle mich müde, Frau Doktor.
Seit drei Tagen oder früher haben Sie...
Seit drei Tagen, vielleicht wegen Schmerzen, aber ich fühle mich nicht gut.
Okay. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewöhnlichkeit abgenommen?
Nein, nein. Ich bin immer gleich sechs oder sechs und 62.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Tapsgefühl oder Kribben mit Ihren Fingern?
Ja, während Schmerzen und Anfall, ich fühle ein komisches Gefühl.
Besonders bei den Händen und Füßen fühle ich ein bisschen komisches Gefühl.
Ich kann es nicht gut beschreiben, aber ich fühle mich nicht gut. Das ist wie ein Taubeisgefühl.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme?
Ja, ich kann es gut sehen, aber bevor Schmerzen hatte ich Lichtblitz gesehen. Das war wie Blitz.
Okay, ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie ein Gefühl, ein bisschen Geräusch?
Ja, während Schmerzen und Anfall habe ich ein bisschen Lichtblitz und ein bisschen Geräusch.
Ja, wissen Sie schon Frau Doktor, wie ein Mann meinen Kopf bohren. Das ist ein Schmerzen wie bohren.
Das ist komisch, aber bohrende Schmerzen habe ich.
Okay, bohrende Schmerzen. Ja, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masalasen oder Schutubgang?
Nein, nein, alles in Ordnung.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Hüschdung?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Haben Sie Herzrasen, Herzstorben oder Herzklopfen?
Okay. Haben Sie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, vor zwei Jahren hatte ich eine Blutgerinnungsstörung.
Deswegen hatte ich eine Sprit genutzt und mit Sprit behandelt.
Und zweimal hatte ich Kaiserschnitt. Ist Kaiserschnitt Operation oder?
Das ist Entbindung.
Okay, haben Sie nur zwei Kinder?
Nein, ich habe vier Kinder.
Zwei natürlich geburt, zwei Kaiserschnitt.
Okay. Und noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, nein, habe ich keine anderen Erkrankungen.
Okay, aber jetzt nehmen Sie keine Sprit für Ihre Blutgerinnungsstörung?
Nein, nein, das war vor zwei Jahren.
Ich habe drei Monate Sprit genutzt und jetzt nehme ich nicht.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein? Bis auf Ibuprofen oder Aspirin oder Paracetamol?
Nein, nehme ich nicht.
Okay. Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Ja, bis auf Kaiserschnitt.
Ja, nur Kaiserschnitt hatte ich zweimal.
Okay. Waren diese Operationen komplikationlos?
Ja, ich hatte kein Problem.
Okay, wann war diese Operation?
Ja, meine letzten zwei Kinder, das war eins vor drei Jahren, eins vor sieben Jahren.
Vor drei und vor sieben Jahren. Okay. Ja, sehr gut.
Und gibt es in der Familie chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit oder Bluthoffdruck?
Ja, leider. Mein Vater ist an Demenz gestorben vor fünf Jahren.
Und meine Mutter ist an Hirntumor gestorben vor drei Jahren.
Ich habe Angst vor dem Doktor. Meine Mutter ist an Hirntumor gestorben. Kann ich eine Hirntumor haben? Oder habe ich sehr schlecht Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, ich weiß ganz genau. Sie wissen, was sie haben. Aber ich habe mir gedacht, dass sie viele Sachen haben.
Zuerst müssen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen. Aber ich habe die Diagnose bis zum Ende unserer Gespräche und alle Ergebnisse erhalten.
Ich halte sie. Ich gebe sie alle wichtigen Informationen.
Okay, Frau Doktor.
Okay, rufen Sie Kratz?
Nein, ich raufe nicht, Frau Doktor.
Okay, sehr gut. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke ab und zu. Aber am Wochenende besonders trinke ich gerne Bier und Wein mit meinen Freunden und Freundinnen.
Ein Bier oder ein Glas Wein?
Ja, manchmal ein Glas, manchmal zwei Glas. Manchmal ein Flasche Bier.
Okay. Hatten Sie jemals Kontakt mit Drogen? Das ist eine rätumästliche Frage.
Nein, nein. Ich habe niemals.
Okay. Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja, ich laufe gerne. Drei Mal pro Woche laufe ich.
Ja, sehr gut. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Ja, vor sechs Monaten war ich in Mallorca.
Mallorca.
Bei meinem Urlaub in Mallorca, in Spanien.
Sechs Monate? Vor sechs Monaten?
Ja, vor sechs Monaten.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ja. Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Haben Sie Allergie? Haben Sie gegen Allergie etwas?
Ich habe keine Allergie, Frau Doktor.
Okay. Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich bin Maklerin.
Maklerin?
Maklerin, ja.
Maklerin. Könnten Sie ein bisschen erklären?
Ja, ich arbeite, Wohnung zu mieten und Wohnung zu kaufen.
Ich helfe Menschen, Wohnung zu kaufen oder mieten. Maklerin.
Okay. Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin geschieden.
Geschieden. Das tut mir Entschuldigung.
Geschieden und Sie haben vier Kinder.
Ja, Frau Doktor. Es ist sehr schwer für Kinder, die sich allein kümmern.
Allein.
Das ist sehr schwer. Ich bin immer unter Druck im Arbeit.
Ich bin unter Druck zu Hause.
Vier Kinder kümmern. Es ist sehr schwer.
Eines im Kindergarten, drei im Schule. Es ist sehr schwer, Frau Doktor.
Ja, ja. Ich verstehe Sie. Das ist eine schwierige Situation.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Gott sei Dank, sie sind gesund.
Okay. Frau Kraß, ich habe keine weiteren Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Frau Doktor, was vermuten Sie? Was kann ich haben? Ich habe große Angst.
Meine Mutter ist wegen Gehirntümer gestorben.
Ich dachte, dass ich Gehirntümer habe.
Ja, ja. Ich verstehe, dass es schwer ist.
Ich kann Ihre Situation verstanden.
Aber machen Sie sich bitte Sorgen.
Momentan gibt es keinen Grund für Angst.
Das ist so, um etwas zu sagen.
Ich werde Sie jetzt erst körperlich untersuchen.
Dann wird Blut abgenommen und eine Röntgenaufnahme vorgenommen.
Ich werde Ihre Beschwerden mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Dann kommen Sie zurück und eine Erkenntnis erklären.
Okay, Frau Doktor, ich bedanke mich.
Okay. Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen. Haben Sie eine Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Der Patient, der ist 39 Jahre alt, 1,71 Meter groß und 81 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Kraß starrte sich heute bei uns.
Seit zwei Tagen starrte sich bei uns wegen der bestehenden Bohrenden stärker.
Sie beschreibt ihre Schmerzen besonders am linken Seite.
Sie schreibt ihre Schmerzen hinter die Hände, die Gesichter und die linken Augen.
Sie liegt bei 7 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Sie hat Übigkeit und Neusea und dreimaliges Emesis.
Sie hat seit zwei Jahren einhergebe.
Sie ist unabhängig von Schmerzbedingungen in der vegetative Anamnese,
aber sie hat auch Fatigue und klagt über Licht und Geruch.
Während der Angriff fühlt sie sich mit beiden Händen und Früßen ein komisches Gefühl.
Sie hatte vor zwei Jahren eine Blutgerinnungsstörung.
Sie hat eine Gerüntungshema benutzt.
Sie hat aber keine Medikamente mehr.
Vor drei Jahren und sieben Jahren würde sie zweimal einen Kaiserschnitt durchführen.
Sie ist nicht rauhierend und trinkt ab und zu gelegentlich, besonders am Wochenende,
ein Flaschbier oder ein und zwei Gläser Wein.
Sie ist unabhängig von Schmerzbedingungen in der vegetative Anamnese.
Sie hat eine Schmerzkala und eine Schmerzkala.
Sie hat keine Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit.
Sie arbeitet als Möcklerin.
Sie ist geschieden und hat vier gesunde Kinder.
In der Familie Anamnese ist ihr Vater vor zwei Jahren an einem Mann gestorben.
Sie ist gestorben und ihre Mutter ist an einem Gehirntumor gestorben.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben bedeuten am ehesten eine Migräne hin.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben bedeuten, dass die Folgendenmaßnahmen durchgeführt werden,
die körperlichen Untersuchungen und die Labountersuchungen,
wie großes Blutbild und Entzündungsparameter.
Für weitere Untersuchungen würde ich eine Röntgenaufnahme mit Kopf veranlassen.
Ein MRT kann planen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, schlage ich folgende Therapie vor.
Ich würde ein neurologisches Konzil veranlassen.
Und einige Schmerzmittel geben.
Die Veranstalterung der Veranstalterung kommt nicht.
Gehirntumor oder Blutung.
Gehirnblutung.
Nein, Gehirnblutung.
Schmerzunfall.
Apoplex kommen in Betra.
Was erwarten Sie beim Röntgen des Schadels?
In diesem Fall würden wir zuerst CT-Deschadels durchführen.
Und möglicherweise Heirntumor oder Blutung ausschließen.
CT ist besser.
Für weitere Untersuchungen würde ich CT veranlassen.
Welche Computer tomographieren?
Welche Computer? Kontraste.
Was erwarten Sie beim CT-Deschadels?
Für meine Verdachtdiagnose würde ich keine befinden.
Aber ich empfehle diese Untersuchungen um die Gehirnblutung und Tumor ausschließen.
Wie können Sie Meningitis ausschließen?
Meningitis kann uns im Laborparameter sehen.
Ich warte auf eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Welche Zeichen prüfen Sie um eine Meningitis ausschließen?
Körnig und Projeske.
Während der körperlichen Untersuchung warte ich auf eine Meningitis.
Wenn die Patienten eine Meningitis haben, was erwarten Sie bei der Lumbar-Funktion?
Ich habe eine hohe Protein.
Glukose.
Wie können Sie CT-Deschadels aufklären?
CT ist eine Abkursung der Computer Tomographie.
Das ist eine Schmerzlos-Untersuchung.
In dieser Untersuchung bekommen wir eine Patientenschralle.
CT zeigt uns die Knochenstruktur und die Blutung.
Nein, nein.
CT ist eine Abkursung der Computer Tomographie.
Das ist eine Schmerzlos-Untersuchung.
Mit Hilfe der Computer Tomographie werden viele Schnittbilder angefertigt.
Meine Körper?
Nein, die Patienten Körper.
Okay.
Es gibt nichts anderes.
Braucht der Patient nicht zu sein?
Nein.
Für CT-Tomographie brauchen wir keine Nahrungskarenz.
Gibt es eine alternative Methode?
Das ist eine alternative Methode für CT.
Wenn die Patienten keine Strahlen mehr nehmen wollen, können wir MRT bevorsagen.
Wenn die Patienten nicht mehr in die Schmerzen sind, können wir MRT bevorsagen.
MRT?
Ja.
Wie viele MRs gibt es?
Das ist eine Abkursung der Computer Tomographie.
Ja, natürlich.
In diesem Fall würden Sie eine digitale Subsektion an Geographie durchführen?
Nein, in diesem Fall?
Ja.
Das ist nicht meine erste Diagnose.
Okay.
Wann möchten Sie eine digitale Subsektion an Geographie durchführen?
In welchem Fall?
Ich denke, eine Blutung kann ich bevorsagen.
Aber in diesem Fall denke ich keine Blutung.
Oder zum Beispiel in Gefäßerkrankungen kann ich DCA denken.
Welche Gefäßerkrankungen können Sie?
Zum Beispiel Myocardial.
Nein, nein, Gehirngefäßerkrankungen.
Gehirngefäß.
Das kann auch eine Subsektion sein.
Wie viele?
In der Verwaltung.
Ja, in der Verwaltung.
Aber...
Die Blutung und die Anävrisme.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau die Sprache.
Ja, okay.
Wie viele Lumbarpunktionen haben Sie?
Ja, natürlich.
Lumbarpunktion ist eine Wehmachl Lumbarpunktion um die Nervenfluss beurteilen.
Nervenflüssigkeit beurteilen.
Wie die sagen.
Gehirnröcke und Markflüssigkeit.
Und der Patient sitzt.
Der Patient sitzt.
Wir haben eine Nadel zwischen 4. und 5. Wirbelsäule.
Welche?
Lendenwirbelsäule oder Baswirbelsäule?
Nein, nein. Lendenwirbelsäule.
Dann sammeln wir einige Tropfen Nervenflüssigkeit.
Dann werden wir diese Flüssigkeit unter Mikroskopie beurteilen.
Ja.
Wir suchen einige Entzündungen und beurteilen einige Laborparameter.
Glukose, Entzündungsparameter, Başkernübungen, Kuss, Eiweiß.
Schmerzhafte Unterzuchtung?
Nein, nicht Schmerzhafte.
Aber wir können eine lokale Östliche Betreuung einnehmen.
Eine Schmerzhaft und eine Unangenehung.
Ja. Aber wir machen eine Östliche Betreuung.
Wir haben keine örtliche Betreuung gemacht.
Okay.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ich habe etwas Arbeit.